[Music]
in apologizing for comments news who
like really should do that I should I'm
so sorry
never apologize judges Double Down
submitted by this point I don't want to
hurt feelings anymore Barbra Streisand
has apologized after her comments upon
Michael Jackson's accusers what did she
say I don't know [ __ ] safe
Chuck [ __ ]
[ __ ] Robson go to hell [ __ ]
Barbra Streisand saying that that's what
he was thanks Isaac because she would I
don't even know she she did she talk
[ __ ] about them before she didn't talk
[ __ ] but she had some very questionable
remarks in an interview with The Times
so you guys thought leaving Neverland
yeah I can't bring ourselves to watch it
you have to watch it because it's so
crazy it's a little funny I don't even
think that's a documentary I know Wade
Robson
oh you don't personally yeah come on
yeah and your boy Wow
I heard about this trailer five years
can you a since you know wait Robinson
can you ask him why he thought it
wouldn't be funny for him to say Michael
Jackson spread my butt cheeks and hey
look at he jacked off at a corner
because that part had me laughing a
little bit I don't know I get watching
your [ __ ] well you know him are you
guys friends I haven't seen him a while
he's coming
group the same circles dancing he's
actually really cool dude and it's you
is he a man of truth my memory way is
always like a really good guy who I I
don't know man we we both he was always
close to Michael yeah of course he's I
just can't we all ran in the same
circles and we have a lot of similar
friends so again another friend about
this story when he first I guess
realized it yeah had like Total Recall
or something like that and then there's
a few years ago maybe five years ago and
we're like oh [ __ ] I know this was gonna
happen years later but was it when
Michael was alive I want to say he was
dead
hmm I don't remember what a michael died
2009 a free pass to I think 2009 you fit
that night I don't know I mean obviously
things
it was June 25th though I think but it
was in March I feel like I think it's
June 25th I don't know the month there
are the people like kind of like
against the accusers okay so Barbra
Streisand in the interview she said that
she believes they got molested but she
doesn't believe that it impacted them
permanently oh no no not the right
station Michael Jackson's sexual needs
were his sexual needs coming from
whatever childhood he has or whatever
DNA he has you could say molested but
those children as you heard say they
were thrilled to be there they both got
married and they both have children so
it didn't kill him oh my God where are
PR people Cena called the worst example
of being on the fence you should have or
the [ __ ] other did she's like I'm
gonna let me give you my two cents about
molestation I should be the PR person
give me a [ __ ] keyboard snap it and
throw it away I feel like anyone over
the age of 60 is allowed to say whatever
the [ __ ] they want cuz they're in a
different world and they grew up in a
way more gangster time yeah she's like
she's probably like you know how many
times I'd be raped
she's probably like quit your bitching
yeah people are always saying that [ __ ]
to us and we're saying that the younger
people just like you right like yeah
what the [ __ ] am I gonna say you know
that everyone yeah like going through
show business I but maybe she has her
fair share of that and she don't kill me
somewhat didn't kill you while she's
[ __ ] downing all this [ __ ] liquor
to try to forget and suppress all these
memories right so she had to make up she
had to come up with a new statement yes
what's that drug that everyone's taking
that maybe it's I was on too much the
Roseanne Barr she's really got [ __ ]
[ __ ] people I haven't seen the show but
I it is like interesting like the are
killing thing popped off and like no
one's playing on account like aren't
Kelly's like dead
I was playing a shit-ton of r.kelly knew
I played so much our Kelly after that
because they just sparked a little
emotion I was like before he gets
completely canceled it's the remix teams
like favorite but Mike hasn't really
talked a little more I haven't listened
on Kelly no no wow means when dave
chappelle did that I'm gonna pee on you
like that was hilarious right yeah
because they were just bland but there
were videos weird so we were all hoping
that our better judicial system was
doing their [ __ ] job
we were hoping for like him they know
it's not being he's not being canceled
out it's hard to cancel well they were
trying to he's a music icon it I'm not
saying he's gone forever
yeah play but you get so hard to cancel
him because he's he's past like he can't
come out and be like yes no you can't
plus he's dead alright Kelly's still
alive stop-in what's crazy is there's a
video I remember well I forgot what you
video was but there's Michael Jackson in
a limousine and he's singing aren't
Kelly's remix remake surprise that's not
circling mine no I gotta watch that he's
like this much I mean it's me know this
like a lot of freaking music everybody's
they like so many artists have been so
[ __ ] up Jerry Lewis was a pedophile
Elvis was a pedophile but generally this
was with this cousin or something right
a [ __ ] incestual pedophile you can do
that wasn't they Woody Allen yeah
one gallon yeah doctor the Asian girl
and then married her later
[ __ ] that kids with their yeah I don't
want that's the worst that's a clear
pedophile do you want to read her new
statements that came out on Barbra
Streisand
yeah she switched up I'm profoundly
sorry for any pain or misunderstanding I
caused by not choosing my words more
carefully about Michael Jackson and his
victims because the words printed do not
reflect my true feelings
I didn't mean to dismiss the trauma
these boys experienced in any ways what
I'm saying is that little [ __ ] like
all survivors of sexual assault they
would have to carry this for the rest of
their lives I feel deep remorse I hope
that James and Wade know that I truly
respect and admire them for speaking
their truth switch I think someone
someone knew completely broken yes by
the previous PR person to hire a new
pool who's asking barbers tries in about
exactly exactly what the [ __ ] please
tell us your dick is way more relevant
than the other nobody 20 because none of
them have anything to do with that
Barbra Streisand's that relevation you
know in all honesty like Barbra
Streisand not only is she I guess like
technically not really relevant now and
on top of that she's so [ __ ] rich you
don't have to take anything back you
don't have to take nobody gives a [ __ ]
about you sturgeon and you're a legend
and you're ballin so she could've just
been like this is what I'm saying [ __ ]
I got millions [ __ ] my [ __ ] and then
move on yeah what are we gonna say why
does she have to put her champagne down
and come down like 40 flights of stairs
announce to the world when she thought
just keep relaxing up and Beverly Hills
rose bush was she on Twitter yeah that
was golden Laura interview was in The
Times Magazine
asking her about Michael Jackson times
even put that over cuz he like drama I
don't know maybe she had a friendship
with Michael because my plan a lot in
game I've had a lot of weird friendships
right she's a singer you know like a new
singer and just say no comment
man I dug a lot of a lot more evidence
because one of the things I was where I
was wondering about was no one really
knows
James save Chuck right and no one no one
knows like motive wise why is he doing
this is it just jinx so there's two guys
there's Wade and then there's James safe
Chuck and a lot of people are saying
well Wade is questionable as integrity
is questionable because we don't know
but James safe Chuck seems like he's
telling the truth and this and that and
it's it raids is it questionable yeah
because there's a lot of life well cuz
like first of all Bend if you was yeah
he defended Michael twice and in he's
retracting the statement but he also was
during that time of being during the
alleged molestation time he was dating
Michaels nice and and then for her she's
like it doesn't make any sense and then
if you hear her side which she's not
getting any mainstream publicity I don't
know why she's getting all these like
interviews canceled but her story would
basically they kind of nullify his
crumble his case because I be sure he
could be molested on this case for money
is that true that is the thing so James
save Chuck and Scott wait Robson's
trying to sue the state for 1.65 billion
or some [ __ ] like yes the craziest state
the estate of Michael Jackson's the
state of Michael Jackson
yeah what they're doing right now
actually I guess that clouds it a little
bit if they just do the thing I think
that one on money you're right we just
want to curse [ __ ] up so the motive is
so so the the Jackson family the motive
they're saying that their motive is
money right so no one knows why James
safe Chuck's family would need money
because he's a software engineer or
something like that he's
more money he wants a bill you know why
I found out why okay check this out in
the documentary or the Neverland story
right
James safe Chuck's family owns a garbage
company right there in the garbage
business so so but there's internal
drama within their family and they're
getting sued for 800,000 or some amount
there's a court document out there now
his parents are asking him to help
rescue them but he doesn't have that
kind of money either so he is in deep
money trouble which is very convenient
because the year that they got sued is
when he joined rave womp Robinson's
lawsuit yeah I mean it doesn't discredit
people like people could try to let
sleeping dogs lie and then now they are
in a situation where they need the money
like wow I guess I could wake that dog I
don't want to but me right I mean I was
not in the room so I can't say that they
were molested or they weren't right it's
just that now I'm questioning the motive
of coming out right because I can kind
of see why Barbara Streisand said what
she said you know because it might be
that maybe they came to terms with their
molestation but now it's a convenient
way to export the family because that
can't happen as well right like let's
say I got bullied and I was fine with it
but then you know now this person that
bullied me is famous right and then like
I want to come out and I'll tell you
well people saying don't mess with the
Jacksons the Jacksons they have been
airtight you know how many times had
been sued they went through Michaels
thing when I was alive so I mean like it
ain't gonna be easy to get 1.5 billion
dollars from the Jackson well
technically though Jackson is state none
of that money goes to the Jackson family
it only goes to the mother and then the
three kids of Michael so the Jackson so
everyone thinks that the Jackson family
all benefit from this they don't get any
of that money I also read that this
state is suing HBO yes because of they
have a contract about not showing
Michael in a negative light or
having a first pass at it because they
had exclusive rights to air Michael
material or something like that
there's no damning evidence like our
Kelly either there's videos with our
Kelly yes so when Michael Jackson for me
it's just like I have no opinion really
I'm just like listen cuz we weren't in
there we don't know if they got molested
or not that's what we can't say these
two sus that's all it is that's what I'm
saying yeah I'm just like I'm just like
as a comic I'm just laughing at
everything that's all I could do Bill
Cosby to in the very very beginning and
he's like 40 more women came out so
maybe I mean well I mean it's yeah it's
hard to defend
here's your hero and he's getting
accused of this horrible thing I
adamantly defended Cosby
but then after like now there are
stories about cause II for you yeah
there's that and there's also after like
you know woman 96,000 came out I'm like
okay well hold on say that makes sense
yeah Weinstein - yeah that makes sense
but no one else is coming out from
Michael yeah and there were hundreds of
kids there at Neverland Ranch all the
time but we're out so it takes one no
wait Robinson was a cute ass kid though
he has some sweet cheeks
and there could be a statute of
limitations and he's weights
[Music]
[Music]